Ladies and gentlemen, Aziz Ansari. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Last year, I was asked a host in event in Washington DC with a comedian Aziz Ansari. You might know him as Tom Havifert from Parks and Recreation or you might be binge watching his original series on Netflix, Master of None. What you might not know is that Aziz is also interested in human behavior. He's thought about how social norms have changed the way people get together, he studied
女士们先生们，阿齐兹·安萨里。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。去年，华盛顿特区邀请我在一场活动中担任主持，与喜剧演员阿齐兹·安萨里同台。大家可能通过《公园与游憩》中的汤姆·哈维弗认识他，或者一直在网飞上狂刷他的原创剧集《无为大师》。但你可能不知道的是，阿齐兹对人类行为也非常感兴趣。他思考过社会规范是如何改变人们聚到一起的方式的，他研究了
how romantic preferences have changed over time, and he's examined how online dating is linked to the psychological phenomenon known as the paradox of choice. Like there's too much goddamn jam out there, like there's iPhone apps that literally tell paradox of choice. A Zezus core it in a book with the sociologist Eric Kleinenberg, it's called Modern Romance. We taped a live conversation at George Washington University's List Narodatorium and we played an excerpt for you in the fall. We are working on new podcasts this week and we played an excerpt for you in the fall. We are working on new podcasts this week and we thought you might enjoy this encore presentation.
浪漫偏好如何随时间推移而改变，并探讨了在线交友如何与被称为“选择悖论”的心理学现象联系在一起。就像外面有太多该死的果酱，就像有些iPhone应用字面意思上就在讲述选择悖论。阿齐兹与社会学家埃里克·克莱嫩伯格合著了一本书，名叫《现代爱情》。我们在乔治·华盛顿大学的里斯·纳罗达托里厄姆录制了一场现场对话，并在秋天为您播出了其中的精彩片段。本周我们正在制作新的播客，而我们在秋天为您播出了其中的精彩片段。本周我们正在制作新的播客，我们觉得您可能会喜欢这场返场节目。
If you know anything about a Z's, we don't need to tell you, this episode is going to be a little racy. If you're on the car with kids, you might want to save it for later. I want to jump to one particular section that you start right at the top of the book, looking at ways in which people text one another. And the fact that people turn out to be surprisingly bad at texting. Actually, I should correct that. What you're saying is that men turn out to be surprisingly bad at texting women.
如果你对阿齐兹有所了解，我们就不用多说了，这一集的内容会有点带劲。如果你在车里带着小孩子，你可能想留到以后再听。我想直接切入书中最开头部分的一个特定章节，看看人们发短信的方式。事实上，人们发短信的水平出奇地糟糕。其实，我得纠正一下。你的意思是，男人给女人发短信的水平出奇地糟糕。
Yeah. Well, I will say this, OK? When we ask women, like, well, what are the things you'd like when guys text, like, what are the factors that make a text that you like? And kind of the consensus we got was asking them to do a specific thing at a specific time, saying something that maybe recalled an interaction some asking them to do a specific thing at a specific time,
是的。好吧，我这么说吧，好吗？当我们问女性，比如，当男人发短信时，你们喜欢什么，什么样的因素能构成一条你喜欢的短信？我们得到的共识基本上是，要求她们在特定的时间做一件具体的事情，说一些或许能让人回想起某种互动的话，要求她们在特定的时间做一件具体的事情，
saying something that maybe recalled an interaction that they had in the past to just show that you were engaged and this was something that you were into. And the last thing was just some sort of humor is also helpful. And when the book we talk about this stuff, and it's not from the perspective of this
说一些或许能让人回想起他们过去有过的一次互动的话，以此来表明你的投入，以及你对这件事很感兴趣。最后一点就是，带点幽默感也会很有帮助。我们在书中谈到了这些内容，而且不是从“这就是你应该做的”这种角度出发的，更像是“人们怎么会不知道呢，这其实就是你全部需要做的”。就像，标准低得惊人。就像，标准低到这种程度，真的非常、非常吓人。我想知道，能否请你读一读书中关于男人们在这方面做得有多差的一小段节选？你这里正好有一小段，讲的是一个试图给女人发短信的男人。在第42页，谁想看可以翻到那一页。好吧。好吧。有些人说，你给别人发短信的内容根本不重要。他们喜欢你，就会喜欢你。在采访了数百名单身人士后，
is what you should do, more like how the people people not know like this is all you have to do. Like, the bar is startlingly low. Like it's this really like very scary how low the bar is. I'm wondering whether we can have you just read a short excerpt from the book that talks about how badly men are doing this. And you have a little excerpt here with a guy who tries to text a woman. It's on page 42 for anyone if you want to be a girl. Okay. Okay. Some people say it doesn't matter what you text someone. They like you, they like you. After interviewing hundreds of singles,
我可以以科学的名义确认，这完全是胡扯。对于那些怀疑我的人，我举一个2014年春天我在芝加哥剧院演出时的例子。在那次巡演中，讲完关于发短信的素材后，我会问台下有没有人最近刚认识了某个人，并且一直在互发短信。如果有的话，他们就会上台，我会挑选几个人，宣读、分析并询问他们消息里发生了什么。在这场特定的演出中，我和雷切尔进行了交流，她在一位好朋友的婚礼上认识了一个男人。碰巧的是，那个男人还是她姐姐的朋友，所以她和对方有很不错的机会开启第一次约会。她是单身，她也有兴趣，他本来只需要发一条简单的短信，介绍
I can scientifically confirm that this is total bullsh**. For those who doubt me, here's an example from a show I did at the Chicago Theater in the spring of 2014. During that tour after material about texting, I would ask if any one of the audience had recently met someone and had been texting back and forth. They had, they would come into the stage and I would pick a few people and read, analyze and ask them about what was happening in their messages. At this particular show, I was speaking with Rachel, who had met a guy at a good friend's wedding. As it happened, the guy was also a friend of her sisters, so we had a pretty good shot at a first date with her. She was single, she was interested, all he had to do was send her a simple message, introducing
一下自己，然后约她做点什么。结果是这样的。他发出了第一条消息。嗨，雷切尔！因为我一直没机会在玛丽莎和克里斯的婚礼上邀请你跳舞，我是克里斯在普渡大学时的老室友。他和你的姐姐给了我你的电话号码。我想打个招呼，顺便通过短信自我介绍一下。
himself, and asking her to do something. Here's what happened. He sends his first message. Hi, Rachel! Since I never got a chance to ask you to dance at Marissa and Chris's wedding, I'm Chris's old roommate from Purdue. He and your sister gave you your number. I wanted to say hi and sort of texty introduce myself.
希望你周末过得愉快。点点点。希望能早日与你聊天。雷切尔在10分钟后回信了。嘿，很高兴认识你。目前正在享受我的生日周末，吃了很多好吃的墨西哥菜。生日赶上五月五日节就是这样。
I hope you had a great weekend. Dot dot dot. Hope to chat with you soon. Rachel wrote back 10 minutes later. Hey, great to meet you. Currently enjoying my birthday weekend with lots of good Mexican food. It happens when your birthday is in Cinco de Mayo.
也希望你周末过得愉快。你很快就回信了。我读了上一条消息才突然意识到，我没有写上我的名字。哈哈哈哈。我是威尔，笑脸。我读了上一条消息才突然意识到，我没有写上我的名字。哈哈。我是威尔，笑脸。祝你生日快乐，并且非常喜欢这个五月五日节。
Hope you had a great weekend too. You wrote back shortly. I totally realize upon reading my last message, I didn't include my name. Ha, ha, ha. I'm Will, smiley face. I totally realize upon reading my last message I didn't include my name. Haha. I'm Will, smiley face. Feliz cumpleaños as well. And totally digging on the synchote of myothene.
雷切尔再也没有理过威尔。在收到几条这种性质的信息后，雷切尔停止了回复。我们谁都不认识威尔。你可能是一个心地善良、温润如玉的帅气男人。但我们能了解到的只有那些信息。而那些信息在我们的脑海中塑造出了一个非常书呆子气、令人毛骨悚然的白人怪胎。终究是个白人怪胎。所以你在书中指出的一点是，当有人给你发短信时，双方会陷入一场漫长的等待军备竞赛。如果你立刻回复短信，你就会瞬间失去所有筹码，因为你表现出了兴趣，表现出了绝望。
Rachel never met Will. After a few messages of this nature, Rachel stopped responding. None of us know Will. You may be a kind, handsome man with a heart of gold. But all we have to go on is those messages. And those messages have shaped in our minds a very dorky, terrifyingly Caucasian weirdo. Finally Caucasian, weirdo. So one of the things that you point out in the book is that there's this arms race in waiting when someone texts you. That if you respond to a text right away, you instantly lose all leverage because you indicate interest, you indicate desperation.
所以当别人给你发短信时，你会选择等待。而现在那个人也在跟你玩同样的游戏，所以他们也会等着不回你短信，于是你们就开始了一场旷日持久的等待游戏。这太诡异了，而且诡异的是，每个人都知道别人在搞什么名堂，却还是忍不住要这么做。就像：哦，你要等20分钟。哦，你刚才开会去了吗？不，你根本没开会，你是故意在等的。好吧，你猜怎么着，我要等40分钟。你刚才开会去了吗？不，你他妈的根本没开会。你是故意在等的。好吧，你猜怎么着？我要等40分钟。我要把时间翻倍，因为我也有别的事要忙。
So you wait when someone texts you. And now that person is playing the same game with you So they wait and respond to texting you and now you have this extended waiting game It's so weird and it's weird because everyone knows what people are doing and they still can do it Like oh, you're gonna wait 20 minutes. Oh did you have a meeting? No, you didn't you were waiting on purpose Well, guess what I'm gonna wait 40 minutes Did you have a meeting? No, you fucking didn't. You were waiting on purpose. Well, guess what? I'm gonna wait 40 minutes. I'm gonna double that shit because I have shit going on too.
其实并没有，但我得假装我有。这太诡异了。你知道，那是让我觉得很有意思的事情。我就想，为什么当我单身而且不得不应付这些时，这种等待会把我逼疯？我简直要疯了，而且你知道的，在书中我们查阅了很多研究，我们和许多非常聪明的人聊过，他们向我解释了这一切，这确实说得通。基本上，这个想法就是，比方说
Not really, but I'm gonna pretend like I do. It's so weird. You know, that was the thing that was interesting to me. Like, I wondered like, why did that waiting drive me crazy when I was single and like had to deal with that? Like, I would go crazy and and you know in the book we looked at a lot of studies we talked to a lot of very smart people and they explained it to me and it made sense like basically the idea is like let's say
你是个男人，你遇到了三个女人，你给她们三个都发了短信，其中两个给你回了信。回信的那两个让你悬着的心落了地，对吧？但第三个没有给你回信。所以她没有让你悬着的心落地，她制造了不确定性。而不确定性非常具有杀伤力，它会死死缠住你的脑海，让你忍不住想：到底怎么回事？我做了什么？我对这个人做什么不好的事了吗？我招人喜欢吗？发生什么了？发生什么了？所以那个人在你的脑海中占据了更多的心智空间。而仅仅是这种在脑海中的存在，有时就能转化为吸引力。所以当她们最终让你悬着的心落地时，对你来说意义就更重大了。
you're you're a guy you meet three women and you text all three of them and two of them write you back the two that write you back they kind of put your mind at ease, right? But the third one has not written you back. So they're not putting your mind at ease and they've created uncertainty. And uncertainty is very powerful and it sticks to your mind and you're like, what's going on? What did I do? Did I do something wrong to this person? I like me. What's happening? What's happening? And so that person has more presence of your mind. And just that presence on your mind can sometimes develop into attraction. So when they finally do put your mind at ease, it's more meaningful to you.
但某种程度上，在某个特定时间点，如果你等得太久，对方就会觉得，算了吧，这人太能端着了，等这么久，去他的吧，我要跟那些给我迅速回信的其他人中的一个出去玩，诸如此类的。所以这从来都不是一个精确的定论。没有什么话是可以让你说出来之后，
But there's also kind of like, at a certain point, if you wait too long, then the person's like, well, screw this person, like they wait too long, like screw them, I'm gonna hang out with these, one of these other people that wrote me back quickly or whatever. So it's never quite a precise thing. There's not like something you can say where
就觉得，好吧，如果你等这么多少分钟，结果就会完美无缺。所有这些情况因人而异。里面有很多因素。但我们学到的一点是，随着年龄越来越小，那个等待的时间量会减少。如果你告诉——我32岁了，如果你跟某个——我的眼睛就像是，哦，如果他们等了，你知道的，一天或者大约六个小时，会让人有点心神不宁。如果你跟某个处于大学阶段的人交流，他们会说：我五分钟都没收到消息了。发生什么事了？那个时间窗口变得越来越小。
it's like, okay, if you wait like this amount of minutes, you're going to be perfect. Like all those things vary from person to person. There's a lot of factors. But the thing we learned is like that, that amount of time decreases as you get to younger people. Like if you tell I'm 32, if you talk to someone, my eyes are like, oh, if they wait like, you know, a day or like six hours, it's a little unnerving. If you talk to someone who's like, in college, they're like, I haven't heard anything in five minutes. What's happened? That window is getting smaller and smaller.
当我们回来时，我们将讨论日益扩大的约会选择池如何既是一场福气也是一场诅咒。这与心理学上一个被称为“选择悖论”的概念有关。当你约会或者买果酱时，选择太多可真不是件容易的事。你知道，你约会时去了趟洗手间，结果收到几条果酱般的短信，你会想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？请不要走开。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。
When we come back, we'll talk about how the ever-growing pool of dating options can be both a blessing and a curse. This is related to an idea and psychology known as the paradox of choice. Having too many choices can be tough when you're dating, or when you're buying jam. You know, you go on a date and you go to the bathroom like a few pieces of jam, of text to you, you're like, what the f*** is this? Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain.
阿齐兹·安萨里在书中谈到了如今人们拥有的海量约会选择。这引出了一个在社会科学中被深入探讨的概念，它被称为“选择悖论”。对于现在正在约会的人来说，最大的改变之一就是你拥有的选择比以往任何一代人都要多。你知道，当我们和那些住在养老院之类地方的人交谈时，就是你拥有的选择比以往任何一代人都要多。当我们和那些住在养老院之类地方的人交谈时，真的很有趣。
Aziz and Sarri talk in his book about the vast number of dating choices people have today. This led to an idea that's been explored in the social sciences, it's known as the paradox of choice. One of the big changes for people that are like dating now is you have more options than any generation of people ever. You know, when we talk to people that were living in retirement homes and stuff, it was you have more options than any generation of people ever. When we talked to people that were living in retirement homes and stuff, it was really interesting.
他们谈到了——尤其是女性——这真的很有趣。她们说，嗯，你知道的，20岁的时候。我跟父母住在一起。我没有机会去追求教育或我自己的事业。直到我结婚，我才真正成为一个成年人。附近有个小伙子。人挺不错的。我想离开这个家，当时我就想：好吧，我要结婚了，你知道的。她们真的是这么说的，当时我想：听起来确实是这样，因为她们中的一些人
They talked about how, especially the women, it was really interesting. They were saying, well, you know, it's 20 years old. I was living with my parents. I didn't have the opportunity to pursue education or my own career. I didn't really get to become an adult until I got married. There was some guy with neighborhood. He was pretty nice. I wanted to get out of the house and I was like all right I'll get married, you know And they really said that I was like it sounds like it because they're like some of the women
真的很高兴，她们会说：哦，我们慢慢培养出了这种深厚的羁绊。但另一些女性则会说：不，没那么深厚的羁绊。对那些代际的人来说，结婚可以说是迈向成年期的第一步。但对我们而言，现在的人，婚姻往往不再是第一步。你知道的，你上大学，你追求事业，你在很多不同的地方生活，并在你人生的这些不同阶段遇到形形色色的人。你拥有了整整一个被称为“新兴成年期”的人生阶段，是的，你通过这种方式遇到了那么多人，然后再加上在线交友这一块，你的选择就更多了，
They're really happy and they're like oh we grew to have this debon but other women are like no not as much of a bond and And getting married was kind of the first step in adulthood For those generations. But for us, this, you know, people now, marriages is always the first step. You know, you go to college, you pursue a career, you live in a bunch of different places, and you meet so many people throughout all these different stages of your life. You have this whole stage of life that is referred to as emerging adulthood and yeah you meet so many people that way and then you add in the online dating aspect of things and you have more options
多到养老院里那些世代的人们做梦也想不到的程度。所以我的意思是，我能理解为什么只有三个人的约会池太小，以至于无法真正找到你的终身伴侣，但一个拥有三万或三十万人的约会池却又让人根本应接不暇。因为情况是这样的，每当你遇到一个可能有趣的人时，你脑海深处的那个小声音就会说：如果你再等两天，你就能找到比这个人更好的人。好吧，是的，问题在于，我们所指的——我们在书中采访过的这位绅士巴里·施瓦茨，他对选择做了大量研究，并且写了一本
than anyone could have possibly imagined in those generations of retirement homes. So I mean I can see why a dating pool of three people is too small to actually find your life partner but a dating pool of 30,000 or 300,000 is just unmanageable because what happens is every time you meet someone who's potentially interesting, a little voice in the back of your head says, if you wait for another two days, you could find someone better than this. Well, yeah, well, the problem is, what we refer to, what this gentleman, Barry Schwartz, that we interviewed in the book, he does a lot of research on choice and he wrote this book
名叫《选择悖论》的书——那本书的核心论点大致就是这种观点：你知道的，当你拥有更多选择时，你的直觉就是，哦，那太好了，我有更多选项、更多东西可以挑，我会更幸福。但在现实中，他们经过了一项又一项的研究发现，你拥有的选择越多，做决定就越困难；而当你终于做出决定时，你的满意度反而会更低，因为你会一直在琢磨自己是不是做错了决定，或者其他某个选项是不是会更适合你。
called The Paradox of Choice and kind of the kind of main thesis of that book is the idea that like you know when you have more options your instinct is oh well that's better I have more off than more things to choose from I'll be happier. But in reality when they do study after study they find the more options you have the harder it is to make a decision and when you do make a decision, you end up being less satisfied because you're thinking about whether you made the wrong decision or whether one of these other things would have been a better match for you.
然后，那个非常著名的研究是他们在一家杂货店做的实验，他们摆出了两个不同的果酱展示台。一个展示台大约有五种果酱，另一个展示台大约有——你知道的，五种果酱，而另一个展示台大概有36种果酱。当展示台只有五种果酱时，人们购买果酱的可能性要大得多；而当展示台有36种果酱时，人们简直不知所措，根本不知道该怎么办，有时甚至最后连果酱都不买了。所以，他们还说了这样一件事，真的很有趣，他们说：哦，从那36种果酱——也就是那个更大的展示台买果酱的人，不管怎样，如果我把这些数字记错了，
And then the really famous study is this study they did in a grocery store where they had two different displays with jams. And one display had like five jams and one display had like you know five jams and the other display had like 36 jams and whenever it was the five jams people were way more likely to buy the jams and when they had the 36 jams they were just overwhelmed and they didn't know what to do and they ended up not buying jams sometimes. So and they also said this which is really interesting they said like oh people that bought the jam from the 36, like the bigger display, whatever, if I'm getting these numbers wrong,
我是在意译，但核心意思是准确的。当他们从选项更多、展示更大的那个买时，人们报告说对果酱的满意度更低，我觉得这简直太荒谬了。这种想法是：有人吃了果酱，然后觉得：这果酱真不令人满意。这果酱有什么毛病？上面写着它是草莓味的呀。但在书中我们说的是：在我看来，这完全适用于现代浪漫，因为我的意思是，外面有太多该死的果酱了。就像，你知道的，你约会时去了趟洗手间，
I'm paraphrasing, but the core of the thing is right. The, when they bought from the one with the bigger display with more options, the people reported being less satisfied with the jam, which I found really hilarious. The idea that someone ate jam and like, this jam's not satisfying. It's wrong with this jam. It says it tastes like strawberries. But the thing we say in the book is like, to me, like that totally applies to modern romance, because I mean, like, there's just too much goddamn jam out there. Like, you know, you go on a date and you go to the bathroom
收到了几条果酱般的短信。你会想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？你上网去，外面有那么多的果酱。有些iPhone应用字面意思上就会告诉你附近有没有想要在此时此刻被“吃掉”的果酱。我的意思是，你能怎么办？你知道，你在书中谈到了你采访过的那个家伙，我想他是在match.com上
like a few pieces of jam of text to you. You're like, what the fuck is this? You go online, there's so much jam out there. There's iPhone apps that literally tell you if there's jam nearby that wants to get eaten at that very moment. I mean, what can you do? You know, you're talking the book about this guy you interviewed who I think was on match.com
而且你实际上有机会观察他做决定，当时他正在浏览女人的照片，然后决定自己是否喜欢她们。我不知道你是否还记得这个具体的趣闻，但我想知道你能否跟我们讲讲。记得，我记得这家伙。所以他这个人——他看起来不像是那种——他可不是什么猛男帅哥，他不是那种型男，他给人的感觉就是那种——这话可能有点刻薄，但他给人的感觉就是那种平庸的白男。然后他登录了自己的账号，账号显示——哦，在这个案例中他用的是match.com账号。他看着账号，然后就觉得——而且上面写着：你有这么多匹配对象。我看着那张照片，
And you actually got to observe him making choices where he was sort of reviewing pictures of women And then deciding whether he liked them or not I don't know if you remember the specific anecdote, but I'm wondering if you can just tell us about it Yeah, I remember this guy. So he just, he didn't seem like a, like he wasn't like a hunk or anything like, he wasn't a stud, he was just kind of like, and this is mean, but he was just kind of like a mediocre white guy. And he, uh, he logged on to his account and, and it said like, oh, he was a match.com account in this case. And he looks on it and he was just like, uh, and, and said like oh you he was a match.com account in this case And he looks on it and he was just like and it said like you have these many matches and I looked at the photo
心想：哇，那个女人非常有魅力。然后他看着她的个人资料，琢磨着自己到底要不要给她发条消息。他说：“算了。”当时我就想：什么？为什么？你为什么不给她发消息？他说：“嗯，她喜欢红袜队。”当时我就想：什么？然后我看到他点进另一个女人主页，无视了她。接着他又无视了另一个女人。然后他给这个女人发了一条简短的消息。这简直让我大开眼界。
I was like wow that woman is very attractive and then he he looked at her profile and He was like debating whether he's gonna send her a message. He's like nah, and I was like what? Why why are you not sending her message? And he is like, mm, she likes the red socks. And I was like, what? And then I saw him go to another woman and ignore her. And then he ignored one other woman. And then he sent this other woman like a quick message. And it blew my mind.
因为如果那另外三个被他打叉的女人中的任何一个，在20年前的一家酒吧里看到他，并且对他笑一笑的话，他肯定会——他肯定会欣喜若狂的。那是些漂亮的女人。她们非常有趣，而且——仅仅根据我在个人资料里看到的那么一点信息——看起来像是聪明、体贴的人，总之，她们看起来很有趣，对于这个家伙来说，能和她们在一起简直是高攀了。但现在他却一副“天哪，无所谓啦”的态度。就像外面有那么多
Because if any of those other three women that he put an ax on, if they'd seen him in a bar, like 20 years ago and like smiled at him, he would have, he would have went crazy. He would have crazy. There's beautiful women. They were very interesting and and and seem like intelligent thoughtful people just, you know, based on what little ice off in the profile, but they seem like interesting people where he would be a catch for this guy. But now he was just like, man, whatever. Like there's so many
人，谁在乎呢。所以，但我觉得你所描述的这件事真的很可悲，那就是人们在看着这些照片，并根据极其极其有限的信息对另一个人做出评判，而且往往是根据他们自己认为对自己很重要的标准来评判。
people out here who cares. So, but here's was just like, man, whatever, like there's so many people out here, who cares? So, but here's the thing that I find really sad about what you're describing, which is that people are looking at these pictures, and they're making judgements about this other person based on this very, very small amount of information, and often based on things that they think are important criteria to them.
所以如果你问大家，他们会告诉你，我想要一个身高多少多少、或者多高多矮、什么发色、或者什么身材比例的人，诸如此类。但如果你实际去看看人们最终和谁在一起的数据，人们往往并没有和他们嘴上说自己真正在找的人在一起。所以如果他们根据自己以为拥有的标准去淘汰别人，他们可能正在亲手淘汰自己的灵魂伴侣。
So if you ask people, they will tell you, I want someone who's this tall or this short, or this color hair, or this body profile, and so on. But if you actually look at the data of who people end up with, people often don't end up with the people that they say they're actually looking for. So if they eliminate people based on the criteria they think they have, they might be eliminating their soulmates.
完全正确。是的。我的意思是，有大量研究表明，我们对于自己真正喜欢什么一无所知，你知道的。每当他们查看这些在线交友网站，看看人们嘴上说自己偏爱什么，以及他们实际上在追求什么时，总是——总是存在着巨大的反差，就像：你明明说过你不喜欢这个，但这其实正是你感兴趣的。我觉得这可以追溯到这样一种观点：你知道的，所有这些在线交友网站，你拥有各种过滤器和各种功能，但其实没有一样真正重要。这真正关乎的，
Exactly. Yeah. I mean, there's a plenty of studies that show that we're horrible at knowing what we really like, you know. Whenever they look at these online sites and they see what people say they prefer and what they actually go after, it's always there's always a big contrast of like what you said you didn't like this, but that's actually what you're interested in. I think that goes back to this idea of like, you know, all these online dating sites, you have all these filters and all this stuff, but not of it really matters. Like, it's really just
其实是你在现实中与某人的这种连接，看看是否存在某种火花或联结。当你在现实生活中与某人建立这种联结时，你不会停下来然后说：等等，等等，等等，先别动。你最喜欢的电影是什么？不，你根本不在乎，你正沉浸在与对方的互动中，你觉得很开心，很有趣。而且我觉得有时候在这些在线网站上，那些似乎有点沮丧的人，往往是那些试图找到完美伴侣、并花大量时间来回发消息、试图找到那种难以捉摸的默契的人。但事实上，这种默契只有在现实中才能找到。我觉得在线交友带来的一个重大启示，正如海伦·费舍尔这位女士告诉我们的那样——她是一位极其聪明的社会
about like this connection that you have with someone in person and seeing if there's some sort of spark or connection, like, when you have this connection with someone in real life, you don't stop and go, wait, wait, wait, hold on. But what are your favorite movies? Like, you're just, you don't give a s***, you're engaged with the person and you like it and it's fun. And I think sometimes with these online sites, the people that seemed to be a little frustrated were people that were trying to find this perfect person and spending this extended period of time like messaging back and forth and trying to find this elusive rapport. And really, you just find that in person. And I think one of the kind of big takeaway from online dating was what this woman Helen Fisher told us is and she's like this amazingly smart social
学家。她也跟match.com合作过，她说：“你知道的，这些网站不应该叫在线约会科学，而应该叫在线介绍服务，因为你的目标是跟这个人在线下见面。”当我意识到这一点时，就像是：你知道的，你无法在网上遇到完美的人，你在网上遇到的是一个人；但要发现他们是否完美，你必须看看你们在现实中相处得怎么样。换句话说，你真的必须要经历大约第三次约会，
eyes. She's also works with match.com and she's like, you know, these sides shouldn't be called online dating science as you're called online introduction services because you want to meet this person in person. And when I realize it's like, you know, you don't meet the perfect person online, you meet a person online, but to find out they're perfect, you have to see how you are in person. So in other words, you really have to get to sort of date three
才能真正弄清楚这个人是否适合你。但如果你一直处于向右滑、向左滑的模式中，你就永远走不到那一步。甚至比向右滑向左滑模式更糟糕的，是这种模式：哦，让我一直发消息，看看这到底是不是我梦寐以求的人。你知道，其实我觉得Tinder
before you actually figure out whether this person is for you or not. But if you're in constantly swipe right, swipe left mode, you're not going to get to that point. Or even worse than the swipe right swipe left mode is this mode of like, oh, let me just keep sending messages and see if this is my dream person. You know, Tinder actually think, and those kind of swipe apps,
和那种滑动交友应用之所以出现，我完全能理解。有些人可能会说：哦，那看起来太肤浅了。这就是张照片，然后仅仅根据外表决定要不要见这个人。但我的意思是，当你走进一家酒吧或派对时，你看着大家，心里也会想：不，不，行，你就是在做这种事。
I totally see why those came about. Like, there's some people that would say, oh, that seems really shallow. This is the picture and just like swipe in the side if you're gonna meet someone. But I mean, when you go into a bar or a party, you're looking at people and going, no, no, yes, you're doing that.
所以我一直在试着内化你的教训，那就是：结识新的人没那么重要，花时间去和你遇到的人相处、从而弄清楚他们是否真的适合你，才更重要。所以我们在书中提到的一点，就是我们所谓的“重复获得喜爱之情的弗洛·里达理论”，基本上就是说——基本上是说，是的，确实有些人，当然啦。
So I'm trying to internalize your lesson, which is that it's less important to meet new people and more important to spend time with the people you meet to figure out if they're actually right-footed. So the thing we mentioned in the book is what we call the flow riota theory of acquired likability through repetition, which basically was basically saying like, yes, there are people, yes, of course.
但我愿意相信，外面有很多很棒的人，也有很多我们轻易就否定掉的人。如果你运用这个理论，这个理论基本上就是：我们所有人就像是一首弗洛·里达的歌，你知道的？你第一次听的时候会想：行吧，弗洛·里达。我以前听过这首了，赶紧拿走，离我远点。然后你不断地听到它，它开始盘旋在你的脑海里，你会想：弗洛·里达，你又来了，让我们摇摆起来吧！今天下午我在阅读书中的一个章节时，勾起了一些多年前的回忆，涉及纽约的某位国会议员。以及他和一位来自拉斯维加斯的、名叫莉莎的女性之间的脸书私信。
But I'd like to think there's a lot of great people out there and a lot of people that were quick to dismiss If you apply this theory, the theory is basically like we're all like a flow writer song, you know? The first time you hear us you're like all right flow writer. I've heard this before Get it out of here, leave me alone And then you keep hearing it and it gets stuck in your head and you're like, flow right at you, you've done it again, let's dance! I was reading a section of the book this afternoon that brought back some memories from some years ago, involving a certain congressman from New York. And some Facebook messages he had exchanged with a woman named Lisa from Las Vegas.
我想知道你是否能为我们朗读这段对话。当然。我想问问你，你是否认为这些在线网站和这种技术增加了轻率行为和不忠的风险？当然。好的。我还记得当初读安东尼·韦纳的脸书私信时的情景。轻率行为和不忠的风险。当然。好的。我还记得当初读安东尼·韦纳的脸书私信时的情景。
I'm wondering if you might be able to read this exchange for us. Sure. And I want to ask you whether you think these online sites and this technology has increased the risk of indiscretions and infidelity. Sure. All right. I remember reading the Anthony Weiner Facebook messages. of indiscretions and infidelity. Sure. All right. I remember reading the Anthony Weiner Facebook messages.
看着他只是在给全国各地的随机女性发私信，看着这些消息迅速从无伤大雅升级为极其露骨的性暗示，简直难以置信。这是他和其中一位女性——一个来自拉斯维加斯的名叫莉莎的女士——的一次聊天记录节选。韦纳和莉莎，抱歉把这个话题又扯回来了各位，但它实在太迷人了。
Seeing the way he was just messaging random women all over the country and watching the messages, quickly escalate from innocuous to very sexual with unbelievable. This is a transcript of a chat session he had with one of these women, a lady named Lisa from Las Vegas. Weiner and Lisa, sorry to bring this back guys, but it is fascinating.
莉莎：我在试图寻找那位美妙的安东尼·韦纳，因为前几天他对那些该死的共和党人大吼大叫而让我坠入爱河，而且你在《每日秀》上搞笑的功力简直绝了。你的好友请求满了。你必须加我好友。你太棒了。安东尼：谢谢你，莉莎。很高兴你支持我。你的好友请求满了。你必须加我好友。你太棒了。安东尼：谢谢你，莉莎。很高兴你支持我。你一直在关注那个怪胎分享的竞选标语吗？莉莎：她有多疯？谁需要社会保障、医疗保险或教育？如果这个怪咖赢了我所在的州，我发誓我不得不搬家了。她可能比佩林还要蠢，而这真的很难超越。
Lisa, I'm trying to find the wonderful Anthony Weiner who I fell in love with for yelling at those damn Republicans the other day, and you were as funny as hell on the daily show. Your friend requests are full. You must friend me. You were awesome. Anthony, thank you Lisa. Glad you had my back. Your friend requests are full. You must friend me. You are awesome. Anthony, thank you Lisa. Glad you had my back. You keeping an eye on that. Wackadoodle sharing an angle for us. Lisa, how insane is she? Who needs Social Security, Medicare or education? If this Wacko wins my state, I swear I'll have to move. She may be dumber than plain and that is tough to burn.
我发誓我不得不搬家。她可能比佩林还要蠢，而这真的很难找到。就像这张你帅气的新照片，当你来拉斯维加斯帮我痛击右翼疯子的时候。安东尼：这是我的泳池大头照。很高兴你喜欢。我已经准备好去拉斯维加斯了。白天讲真话，晚上有什么计划吗？问号。莉莎：那真是一个意味深长的问题。我给我们准备了各种各样的夜间计划。你什么时候来？安东尼：不知道，开个我无法拒绝的条件吧。莉莎：为了让我们进入状态，首先我们要连看两集《每日秀》和《科尔伯特报告》。然后，为了真正增添点情调，我们要去跟所有挂着竞选标语的邻居对质。接着，当我们真正火热的时候，我们要去书店，把所有平庸的封底书皮都换成《无畏的希望》的副本！我大概一周做一次这个，你可以看出我是一个非常让人兴奋的女孩。
I swear I'll have to move. She may be dumber than plain and that is tough to find. Like this cute new pick of you, when you come into Vegas to help me beat up the right wing crazies. Anthony, this is my pool my finger shot. Glad you like. I'm ready for a Vegas trip. Truth telling during the day, got a nine plan for us? Question mark. Lisa, that was a very loaded question. I've got all kinds of night plans for us. When are you coming? Anthony, don't know, make me an offer. I can't refuse. Lisa, to get us in the mood, first we watch back-to-back episodes of the Daily Show and Colbert Report. Then, to really spice things up, we go to face all of my neighbors sharing annual yard signs. Then, when we are really hot, we go to the bookstore and cover all of the bland back books with copies of the audacity of hope! I do this about once a week, you can tell I'm a very exciting girl.
或者如果这不是你的菜，我们也可以直接喝醉，然后进行疯狂热烈的情爱。对我来说，最冒犯的部分是他用了“怪胎”（whackadoodle）这个词。最冒犯的部分是他用了“怪胎”这个词。另外，你捕捉到那个滑稽的、几乎是潜意识的、一眨眼就会错过的关于性爱的不经意暗示了吗？就是当她说他们可以进行疯狂热烈的情爱的时候。所以，你对这些怎么看？这些在线技术让我们更容易做出轻率和不忠的行为吗？还是这只是我们一贯本性的一种表现？我觉得这绝对——这绝对是，
Or if this is not your thing, we can just get drunk and have mad passionate sex. For me, the most offensive part was that he used the word whackadoodle. the most offensive part was that he used the word whackadoodle. Also, did you catch that slide, almost subliminal blink and you might miss it allusion to sex? It was when she said they could have mad passionate sex. So, what do you think of these? Have these online technologies made us more prone to indiscretion and infidelity? Or is this just a manifestation of how we've always been? I think it definitely, there's definitely,
如果你想涉足轻率的行为，如果你有这些线上工具，如果你有手机，如果你有手机，你就拥有了一个非常私密的私人世界，你可以在里面进行各种没人知道的破事。就像我们在书里讲述的那个人，他说他有个同事，两人关系挺友好。她已婚，她发了一条关于某事的短信，
if you're trying to get involved in indiscretions, you, if you have these online things and you have your phone, if you have your phone, you have this very private world where you can conduct all sorts of s**t that no one knows about. It's just where we tell in the book of this person who says they were, they had like a work colleague and they were friendly with each other. She was married and she sent like a text message
内容跟工作有关，然后他回了信，后来他看到了某种挺搞笑的事情，让他想起了她，于是他发了一条消息，然后两人开始一来一往地开玩笑，这种默契就开始建立起来了，最后他们俩甚至在电话里发展出了一种非常亲密的关系，开始进行长时间的聊天，这变成了一种非常亲密的关系，并最终导致了一些不忠行为。有趣的是，那个男的当时就说：你知道的，如果我没有手机短信，我就不会发那第一条引发这种默契的消息，
about something once and it was like a work related and he wrote back and then later he saw something that was kind of funny that reminded him of her and he sent a message and they started joking back and forth and this rapport started developing and they eventually had this like very like intimate thing going on the phone where they were like having a long conversations and it became this very intimate thing going on the phone where they were like having a long conversations and it became It's very intimate thing and it eventually led to some some infidelity and It was interesting because the guy was like, you know if if I didn't have text message I wouldn't have sent that first message that started leading to that rapport You know, I would never have called her at her home
我绝不会给她家里打电话说：嘿，你看到那个东西了吗，你知道的。但有了手机，你就可以建立起这种能够迅速升级的东西，你知道的，我绝不会给她家里打电话说：嘿，你看到那个东西了吗，你知道的，但有了手机，你就可以建立起这种能够迅速升级的东西，呃……而且我还觉得，你知道的，在韦纳的那件事里，他其实只是稍微试探了一下水温，就好像：不知道，开个无法拒绝的条件吧。你可以说：哦，那我们去奇利餐厅吧。然后她会说：哦，听起来没劲。
I'd be like, hey, did you see that thing like, you know But with your phone you you can kind of build these kind of things that really escalate very quickly you know i would never have called her at her home and like hey did you see that thing like you know but with your phone you you you can kind of build these kind of things that really escalate very quickly uh... and also i think like you know in the in the in the and the winter thing is like all he's able to test the waters with that meeting a little bit where he's like don't know maybe enough for a rickian refuse you can be like oh well we'll go to chiles and you'll be like all that doesn't sound fun
但她立刻就领会了意图，并开始往性暗示方面聊，而他心知肚明：好吧，这事涉及性，她完全玩得起。然后在他刚才读的那条消息之后，闸门就彻底打开了，接着就是各种照片和所有那些东西。我觉得你无法准确地下定论，说这到底有没有导致不忠行为的增加。
but she she immediately like got it and started getting sexual and he knew, okay, this is a sexual thing, she's down and then after that message that I read, like the floodgates opened and then there was all the photos and all that stuff. I don't think you can kind of accurately say whether it's led to an increase on the amount of infidelity
我确实觉得其中的某些方面让它确实更容易助长这种行为。你在书中谈到的其中一件事是，在线交友正在迅速成为许多人相识的方式，但你也发现，对于同性伴侣来说尤其如此。同性伴侣通过在线交友相识真的已经成了人们相识的主流方式。你觉得为什么会这样？你觉得为什么会这样？
that's going on. I do think there's certain aspects of it that make it a little more lend itself to it. One of the things you talk about in the book is about how online dating is rapidly becoming the way many people meet, but you also find that this is especially true for same-sex couples. That same-sex couples online dating is really become the dominant way people meet one another. Why do you think that's going on? What do you think that's going on what
呃，这其实关乎某种现象——与被称为“细分市场”（thin markets）的概念有关。你知道的，我曾跟这样一位女士交谈过，她到晚年时——她曾经嫁给了一个男人，后来离婚了，然后她基本上决定：你知道吗，我是个同性恋，我一辈子都是个同性恋。
do you think it means well that is about something a phenomenon uh... related to what what referred to a thin markets you know i i spoke with this woman who who like late in her life like she was married to a guy and then she got divorced and this kind of decided like you know what i'm a lesbian like i've been a lesbian my whole life
她住在德克萨斯州的一个小镇上，然后她开始玩在线交友、去约会之类的事情。我当时想了想，心想：哇。如果那是23年前的她，情况就会大不相同了。你知道的，身处德克萨斯州
and she lives in this small town in Texas and she started online dating and going on on dates and stuff like that. And I thought about that. I was like, wow. Like if that was her 23 years ago, that would have been a much different thing. You know, being in a place like Texas
这样一个可能人们对这种事没那么开放的小镇，情况会困难得多，而现在她可以上网，能够结识其他人，这真的是一个巨大的因素。所以这在某种程度上可以说是科技积极的一面，不是吗？因为它允许那些拥有少数群体兴趣（如果你愿意这么说）、或者某种特殊兴趣的人不会永远孤独，而是能真正找到与他们的兴趣、需求相匹配的人，
in a small town where maybe people aren't as open to that kind of stuff, it would have been way harder, whereas now she can go online and she's able to meet people and it's really a huge factor. So this is some way sort of the positive side of technology isn't it, because it allows people who have minority interests, if you will, or sort of special interests not to be lonely forever, to actually find people who match their interests, match their needs,
而这就是科技所促成的。它确实在那些细分市场之类的领域帮了大忙，我觉得这是一个很好的观点：对于所有这些事情，我觉得这本书提出的核心问题之一就是，所有这些东西到底是好是坏？我觉得对于每件事都不是只有一种答案，而是两者皆有，这完全取决于你如何使用这些工具。像在线交友，有一种观点认为：哦，每个人都在看手机，每个人都觉得外面有更好的选择，
and this is what technology is enabled. It's really helped in those kind of end markets or whatever and I think that's a good point that for all these things I feel like one of the big questions a book is asking is, is all this stuff good or bad and I think for each thing it's not one answer, it's both, it really just depends on how you use these tools. Something like online dating, there's one notion of like, oh, everyone's on their phones, everyone thinks that there's something better out there,
这给我的生活增添了太多压力，我讨厌这样。但你也可以看到另一面，比如：现在结婚的人中，三分之一都是通过在线交友认识伴侣的，其中很大一部分人遇到的人，如果不是因为这些网站，他们是根本不可能相遇的。所以你可以这样看：哦，因为这项技术，世界上涌现出了海量的崭新爱情，并且如果没有这些东西，这种排山倒海般的爱情根本就不会存在，我觉得你无法否认这是一个积极的方面。
and it just added so much stress to my life and I hate it. Then you could also look at the other side of like, well, one out of three people that get married now, they meet their spouse through online dating and a huge percentage of these people are meeting people that they would not have met had it not been for these sites. So you could look at it like oh well there's an insane amount of new love in the world that's created because of this technology and there's this overwhelming amount of love that would not even be there had it not been for these things and I feel like you can't deny that that's a positive thing.
以上是喜剧演员阿齐兹·安萨里。他与社会学家埃里克·克莱嫩伯格合著的书籍是《现代爱情》。如果你喜欢这个节目，能帮个忙去苹果播客给我们打个分吗？这能帮助其他人找到我们的节目。事实上，如果你在评论里留下“果酱”（jam）这个词，我们就会知道你是从这一集过来的。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作，本周特别感谢丹尼尔·舒钦和杰伊·西兹。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在脸书、推特和Instagram上关注我们，并收听我在
That's comedian Aziz Ansari. His book written with the sociologist Eric Kleinenberg is Modern Romance. If you like this show, can you do us a favor, go to iTunes and give us a rating. This will help other people find our show. In fact, if you drop the word jam into your review, we'll know you came from this episode. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin, Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak, special thanks this week to Daniel Schuchin and Jay Siz. For more Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram, and listen to my stories
当地公共广播电台的故事。我是香卡·韦丹塔，这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。本集节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vitaantham, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在您的当地公共广播电台播出。我是尚卡尔·维坦塔姆，这里是美国国家公共电台。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。